today's topic uh one of joe biden's
first executive actions was
to make it so that anybody who
identifies as a certain gender can
participate in whatever sport that they
want
and that anyone school who's receiving
funding must allow anyone to
play sports in the general identify
whether it be college
high school whatever and some people
have dubbed it the end of women's sports
and others have said no this is just
inclusivity problem is
um scholarships are involved problem is
a lot of money can be involved
problem is education post-secondary
education
may be at risk because some people are
going to be able to identify whatever
they want get those scholarships
and anyone who's receiving federal
funding which is most schools
will have to abide by those rules look
title 9 was created to allow women to
have the chance and the opportunity to
be able to compete
so that they can show off their skills
against athletes of a comparable level
that's why we separate women's in men's
sport to give women a chance
to do as they please that's why we have
serena williams today
she was playing with the men serena
williams would not exist
the idea that you're going to come in
and put this rule in place you're going
to ruin windsports
and there's no other way around it i'm
not saying that this situation is easy
for the people who identify as a
different i'm not saying any of that
what i'm saying is the solution is not
to destroy
a whole sporting category and remove
people from their only opportunity to
really excel in a sporting
arena so last thing i'm gonna say on
this is this
yup exactly what i was about to say i
wasn't
i was i'm oh i was waiting for you i
don't know
oh yes say it speak on it i don't know
you know like
sometimes some things are so ridiculous
i'm sitting here like
we know this is unfair stop it stop it
and it just seems like
walktivism is just stop it stop it stop
it you know what stop
you know what stop it yeah stop it
listen
this is not like a relationship where
you could tell me to stop don't try to
infringe
don't you i'm not trying to infringe on
your space don't you see that it's a
step forward
and sometimes to yeah it is a step
forward average that's what you're
missing you're missing the whole point
all right this is a step forward all
right and sometimes to make a step
forward you have to go backward
we'll just see you can't do right now
you can't say it's on
so now we'll see you know when you're
going to be able to say something
what when all this is over
and you still won't have to say anything
you're just going to be like
but let's try it let's go ahead and
let's go down that route
they'll see the thing is that's my petty
self talking i'ma be honest with you
this is petty
betty pretty preach um sometimes to be
petty you have to be patient
you have to be patient you see how
abbott was not able to say
anything when you're not able to say
anything like that in those kinds of
situations
sit it out sit this one out you don't
have to always say something
you have to let it unfold just like when
you have a child sometimes
i believe that you can't always be like
hey hey hey watch out watch it no
sometimes
the kid has to break his face and that's
how you learn
remember that [ __ ] i was talking to you
about stop running
now you slipped and you bumped your head
there you go
i bet you won't do that [ __ ] no more
sometimes just let it go
the worst thing i get that can happen is
that you you're you're you're right
that's the worst thing that can happen
if you're wrong then everything is great
told you so i was not that bad all right
cool sorry about that you apologize you
keep it going oh well i thought it would
be something
it's not it's cool but when it happens
you're just gonna be like
how big is a performance gap to take one
example cited by the connecticut female
runners in their complaint against the
connecticut interscholastic
athletic conference the fastest female
sprinter in the world
is american runner allison felix a woman
with more gold medals than usain bolt
yup
her lifetime best for the 400 meter run
is 49.26 seconds
unbelievable based on 2018 datto
nearly 300 high school boys
in the u.s alone could beat it i was
about to say that i was ruining the 449
back when i was in high school
i was when i was in high school and i
was competing i was running in the 4950s
right and you know what the worst part
is
i was not the best i was
not i was not the best my worst was like
55 and i got married
that year and i came off an injury yeah
i came off the injury
i broke two of my bones and one on my
foot in the month
of february and then in june i was
competing
okay that was me in in high school rough
why was it necessary for you to say
uh that anybody tarina uh
couldn't beat the 700th player you right
sir
she's the greatest player female player
that ever lived
then the lady said to me i don't
remember which one but she said
why did you say woman why didn't you
just say the greatest you know tennis
player that ever lived and so then i
felt the need
to defend myself i don't know just
say what i really felt i mean which is
about what i think
she would be i think you're referring to
the fact that i said she'd be about 700
in the world yeah right
i'm just waiting would you like to
apologize uh no
you're miss autistic racist
women's centers are completely almost
two separate sports so
i'm like if i were to play andy murray i
would lose 6060 in
five to six minutes maybe 10 minutes
because
no it's true it's a completely it's a
completely different word the men are a
lot faster
and me and um they they get they serve
harder they hit hard it's just a
different game and
i love to play women's students and i i
only want to play girls because i don't
want to be embarrassed i would not do
the two
i mean even if you move past like the
potential lost scholarships
even if you move past their inability to
receive
achievements and and the camaraderie and
the self-esteem issues that could result
from just
constantly having to lose to people who
are clearly physically just
it's unfair do you know how many like
fortune 500
female leaders come from athletic
backgrounds
you know what i mean do you understand
how much of a trajectory in life you're
going to change for so many people
because you want to be
inclusive you're now going to exclude
the very people from who these sports
were made
guys i'm trying to find
other arguments to help it's a waste of
time
i'm for it the case has been made
science is conclusive what
are we doing i don't know
let's do it i don't know i'm all for it
i mean i told y'all last video
you know what i'm saying twitter has
ruined a generation
apparently twitter is now ruining
president executive orders
this potato let's do it but hey ladies
this is going to be your thing to fight
for i'ma stay out of it from now on
because if y'all not the ones speaking
on this
is a waste of my time so i'ma just let
it at that you can't speak on it
uh i'm saying let's do it let's go
preach right here saying that we should
do it you have to understand one thing
preachers are fatalists
let's go let's all burn
let's burn it all the way
down play the beat
[Music]
foreign
hmm